okay so thank your ship and Noah for
giving me this opportunity to speak and
I'm very excited to present this word so
the title of my work is
indistinguishable kalfa station from
simple to state hard problems new
assumptions techniques and
simplification and this is joint work
with romaine Rachel and Amit so let me
start off by defining formally what
indistinguishable obfuscation is it's
just a poly time compiler that takes in
a circuit C and outputs an equivalent
version of the same circuit C and
further it also has an added security
feature associated with it the security
feature is that if you start with two
circuits which compute the same function
meaning that it can have different
implementation but otherwise it has same
behavior and if it has the same size
then once you office create those
circuits what you get at the end are
computationally hard to distinguish and
this seemingly simple definition has
turned out to have profound applications
in all of cryptography in fact like
these are just few applications just
that I have managed by Darnell piece
aside and so much so that it is now
hailed as one of the like almost a
crypto complete primitives by the
community and so much so that even that
in the first instinct a type every hard
problem has just become too true off the
station at at the problem so for the
rest of my talk I'm going to follow
roughly the following outline first I
will give you a brief survey of what are
the constructions that are known in this
operation and what are the assumptions
that they make and then I'm going to
give our describable main contribution
which is a new assumption and after that
I will lay down a road map which will
mainly describe how we construct
obfuscation based on that new assumption
and also I will describe what are the
technical novelties and what are the
main technical contributions of ever and
after that I will talk about in detail
some analysis that we did on these these
new assumptions and also what
some of the main PRG construction
contributions of our work and so it
turns out that we in this world proposed
some new PRG construction which have
some really nice property so I will
describe that and at the end if I get
time I will talk about some new liquid
resilience lemma that we provide in this
paper mainly to give you a flavor of
what kind of techniques that go into
constructing this work okay so let me
now start off with a landscape of fire
construction so so far all known IO
construction typically fit one or one of
the following mean three four categories
which I have listed down here so the
first set of construction came through
this object known as multi linear max
in fact the first break through world of
virgin tree hill AV aleko Visayan waters
gave a construction of obfuscation based
on a very direct manner they started
with this branching program or they
started with a simple branching program
and then suitably encoded it using
melting in American coatings and that
was the first time candidate later this
paradigm was followed by a bunch of
other words in fact 2018 then the first
attempt at isolating a single simple
assumption that is instance independent
and an assumption based on resilient max
came through the work of GL SW 14 after
that it was following up extensively and
then there was a lot of progress and we
saw at least five constructions where
they proposed obfuscation constructions
based on simple instance independent
assumptions on constant agreement in
your Maps
unfortunately however as of now we do
not know of any single construction that
has managed to give us a simple secure
instantiation of those assumptions and
as you all know the main reason behind
it is that these constructions have been
subject to a lot of propeller
a few years and they've been cycles of
attacks and fixes and then what and this
ends up happening is that these are the
assumptions for a simple sequel
construction for a scene for a secured
construction end up being quite
complicated then they were recently we
have been seeing some other
constructions which Castro confiscation
directly just like JJ chorizo but now
they do not use Maltese knickknacks
anymore in fact they work with some new
kind of mathematics in order to achieve
that so we have seen a couple of words
recently about about those ways then
there is another way of constructing
obfuscation which has recently been
emerging in in those words we typically
come up with frameworks which are
simpler than i/o which look appear
simpler than i/o and then we show that
those frameworks imply obfuscation and
then we proposed candidate construction
for those frameworks so one such
construction was that of noisy linear Fe
which is a framework and the work of
other was in 2019 showed that this noisy
noisy linear Fe is enough to imply
station and then in that work and in a
follow-up work recently in 2020 Kenny
constructions of noisy linear Fe was
proposed relying on security of some
intrude style and coatings and very very
recently in even in fact in last year
okay there's this no new notion of state
equity which I find particularly
exciting where they way they propose
this notion of speed fhe and then they
showed that this implies i/o and they
were able to give candidate construction
of this literacy based on damge Dudek
intention and fully homomorphic
encryption in fact you heard a talk
about this only last week and in the
same seminar but unfortunately however
these two words also do not yield simple
assumptions in fact the assumptions when
you write it down they end up looking
quite complicated so in this world I am
going to talk about constructing i/o
from simple to state assumptions so let
me clarify what
mean by simple to state I mean that
these assumptions on which you want to
construct IO should be instance
independence assent and falsifiable so
in this world I'm going to follow up
mainly on the work of each LMS and G LMS
both of which appeared in 2019 and at
this point let me remark that there's
another work of other one which also
gave a construction of
indistinguishability obfuscation from a
simple to state assumption that can be
instantiated either using the assumption
given in Ag LMS 19 or yr db2
pseudorandomness assumption for which we
do not know of any secure instantiation
as of now and we will not follow up on
that word so today like I just follow up
on G elements so let me now give you the
state of our theorem statement that
appeared in the world of elements 19 the
children said that you can construct sub
linearly efficiency at key from still
encryption from sub-exponential time
hardness of following assumptions the
assumptions are a 6 th assumption over
valuing your Maps the learning with
error assumption boolean PRG is over 4
NC 0 with polynomial stretch and a new
notion which is called as perturbation
resilient generator also abbreviated as
delta RG ok so now I want to remark a
few things about this definition first
that in this word they use some
exponential time hardness of the
following assumptions the first three
assumptions SXT HLW boolean PRG is they
have been out there for a long time
and they are considered standard the
last assumption is then is really the
new assumption so we are going to for
the rest of the talk focus on this new
notion of Delta G and understand our
world with this with comparisons to this
assumption of Delta G and now once you
have I have the sub exponentially secure
functional adduction then you can use
known set of transformation in fact the
sequence of transformations which are
outlined in the world of maybe AJ airbnb
de blue and knt to obtain higher does
anyone have any questions to this point
okay so I'll proceed now in order to
understand our work first let us try to
understand the assumption that was made
on a LMS in a bit more detail so we're
going to look at the structure of the
Assumption on a high level and a high
level roughly the assumption has the
following structure it has to it has
instance of the following form so it has
two components the instance has two
components the first component are some
set of polynomials they are n to the 1.1
polynomials with n inputs okay
so n inputs n to the 1.1 polynomials
with each polynomial have integer
coefficients so they are from zx10 and
they have constant degree okay
and these inputs even through en they
are sampled from integers from a random
domain of patronym from some domain
minus D comma B so these are your
polynomials but along with that the
Assumption also gives some leakages on
these errors on these inputs even to be
n so namely in the assumption there were
also some algebra samples which look
like this you had to fish terribly
samples which used errors a I which
appeared in as inputs to the polynomial
so roughly that was the structure of the
GLM assumption now this is great so but
I would like to point out that there are
some nice properties and then there are
some not so nice properties of this
assumption and interestingly what turns
out is that both nice and not nice
aspects are the same namely this
assumption and the style of the style of
assumption and this area is has been new
any Baltic
so let's look at the positive aspects
first the first aspect is that this
assumption is simple to state so this is
great and what's also interesting is
that it differs from most traditional
crypto which is done over ZP or like
finite groups or f2 and things like that
second nice thing about it is that
historically speaking polynomials have
been around for a long long time and in
fact if you consider a problem of
finding roots that's actually np-hard so
this sort of provides some anecdotal
suggestive plausibility that these
assumptions might have some inherent
hardness in them okay so this is only a
suggestion and the third nice property
is that this is a great reasons to study
average case polynomial inversion
problems because just because this
problem has huge implications in
cryptography let's now see some of the
not-so-nice aspects the main complaint
or the main not-so-nice aspect is that
only proposed recently in 2018 so it has
not been around for a long time and
therefore we do not have a huge body of
cryptanalysis to bat confidence in this
work in fact as I was telling you
earlier since this is different from
traditional crypto which is done over
finite groups or zp and things like that
this is a there's an attack landscape
that is traditionally not considered
that much in cryptography mainly the
attacks that arise from continuous
optimization algorithms and statistical
methods so only time can tell what this
assumption how this assumption turns out
with respect to these new adventure
avenues in considered in cryptography so
that's one of the main downside so the
main question main question that we
consider in this work is that can we
replace these integer polynomials with
something that has have a long history
of study and that has had a long body of
catalysis so that we can't out security
just based on
on those things and in particular more
specific question is can you replace it
with boolean Piaget's that have been
around for a long time with us so in
fact that is what we do in this word we
are going to propose a new assumption an
assumption actually relies on
interaction between two assumptions that
have been around much before our work so
the first assumption is learning with
error with learning with error with
binary noise lve and the second
assumption is pseudo-random generators
in NC 0 with some sufficient state which
I will just 25 okay now let me now go
over these problems and just give you a
brief overview of what they are now
learning with error with binary noise
it's just like lwe where the error
distribution is binary meaning that you
can so let's say the error distribution
can just be 0 and 1 and you are going to
sample a lot of errors from that now for
that turns out this problem is probably
hard when the number of samples that you
gave is linear in the dimension so this
was proven by me Chen Xuan Packard where
they proved they actually gave a
reduction from a worst-case hard lattice
problem to the setting when there are
relatively samples with binary noise
which are the number of them are linear
in the dimension of course the modulus
is chosen some specific parameters which
I will not go which will I will not talk
about right now then when you have the
number of samples which is quadratic in
the dimension then this the Blooey with
binary noise is actually polynomial time
broken and so very simple and elegant
linearization return which was given in
Aurora and gained 2011 as I'm so
actually we weren't in a regime which is
between linear and n square it would
have been nice if you could work with
just linear samples but we can't so
actually we worked with in a regime when
the number of output bits
number of samples that's
that grows like n to the 2 minus epsilon
where epsilon is some constant greater
than zero and under that circumstances
it turns out the best-known algorithm
for a choice of parameters which we use
is 2 to the n to the epsilon and these
are algebraic algorithms relying on
global basis approach and you can find
as this in the following references so
there is a work of Albrecht at all in
2015 and there is a work of chavatal in
19 now let me talk about PR G's in and
c0 sufficient stretch so this as you all
know has a long history of study ever
since the world right in 2000 and best
known attacks so far we know till date
are some exponential even when the
number of output bits the stretch of the
PRG is as large as n to the D over 2
minus epsilon where D is a measure of
degree of the PRG which is called as the
multi degree and i will specify what
this is in just a minute
and there's a huge body of words
supporting this and we however yeah we
will also use a stretch which is lesser
than this n to the 2 minus epsilon so
that's nice
and our assumption will avoid all known
attacks and these are known some
exponential time attacks known in these
literature and also some more attacks
that we consider which I will talk about
later in the talk ok so now let me tell
you formally our assumption but before I
do that let me formally describe what
with binary noise and G's likes in
tactics of those things so let's recall
with binary noise so it it's indexed
with 2 parameters epsilon and Rho think
of their constant epsilon Rho are both
constants and think of the modulus P as
being lesser than 2 to the N to the N to
the Rho
so basically Rho is just telling what
the modulus is and then this assumption
talks about indistinguishable you have
two distributions and distribution D 1
you are given as the base samples which
are generated like AI is less yeah and
so there are n LW samples and there they
are from so the dimension of the
coefficient vectors and the secret is
n to the point 5 plus Epsilon
okay so that's the dimension and the
errors are children from the boolean
distribution 0 1 so that's distribution
D 1 the summation D 2 this consists of
coefficient vectors a I along with that
you have uniformly chosen our eyes from
Z P and all you're asking is that these
two distributions are indistinguishable
then standard sense against polynomial
time variables so that's a little blue B
now let me quickly define what we are
will in PIDs are I'm sure all of you
know this but let me spend just a few
seconds on that so William PIDs they are
low complexity functions that stretch
you yeah it was the point four is
important
in the definition in the assumption on
the previous slide what was the
significance of 0.5 0.5 oh yeah okay so
the thanks for asking I mean that the
number of samples is n right number of
samples and dimension is n to the 0.5
plus Epsilon so that means the number of
samples is dimension to the power 0.5
minus some sorry dimension to 2 minus
some epsilon prime because I mean the
square of this is greater than n square
of this is greater than n does it make
sense yeah thank you the number of
samples is quite in the dimension that's
yeah it's just yeah we could have worked
with this being N and there being
slightly more complicated but turns out
that this is easier enlarge in the view
of larger and I finished like the
definition of our assumption this
notation is simpler okay so as I saying
boolean PRG is their length expanding
low complexity objects so they take n
bits of inputs and output M bits where m
is some polynomial in N and I will
describe exactly what stage we are
working with
and it they have low-complexity meaning
that so you can consider various notions
of complex solutions such as sometimes
you might want PR G's to have low depth
as boolean circuits or low degree or low
locality
I will exactly describe what complexity
measure we are working with and security
notion as you all know is that when you
apply the PRG or a random input that
looks indistinguishable to a truly
random string of length m to any
computationally bounded adversity a okay
so as I was saying we use this
complexity measure so let me now define
what complexity measure we are using we
are going to use multi linear degree
informally we will also call this to be
degree of the PRG over the years so
let's see what it is so let's say you
have an input X and 0 n to the N you
compute a y1 through yn as an output of
the PRG now I'm going to define GN I as
a function that computes the eye out bit
of the output so it's a boolean function
but you can also write it as a
polynomial over the years it you can
write it on in fact as a multi linear
polynomial and this multi linear
polynomial ax is going to be unique okay
and we're going to define di as the
degree of this polynomial over the years
and simply the multi no degree of the
PRG is the maximum of all degrees from I
in 1 to M now just for the sake of
clarity let me define one way in which
you can write this multi linear
polynomials so you so if you have a if
you have a circuit like that you can you
can replace gate by gate each gate with
the polynomial so suppose you
encountered X 1 X or X 2 you can replace
it with this polynomial suppose you
encountered X 1 and X 2 you can just
replace with the multiplication and
finally as everything is a book as
boolean as every variable as boolean
simply XS queries xn okay so this allows
you to write machinery polymers and in
fact I worked out an example like this
so if you want I can stop here at Norman
but it's really something that you could
figure out offline
and it's really simple okay so now we
have seen the definitions of binary
Louie and PRG so we are now ready with
our main assumption under the main
assumption is actually really simple and
it borrows parameters epsilon and row
from binary other Bui and it gets
parameter G and it's degree for the
multi degree from the pIJ assumption and
now it's an inadmissibility of two
distributions in the first distribution
you have by radial degree samples ai ai
S Plus e I we are he is not chosen from
0 1 there are a multiple samples with
dimension n to the 0.5 plus epsilon the
modulus was chosen according to be less
than n to the Rho as I've described
before along with that you are going to
give out PRG evaluation on the input
error vector on the error vector
basically PR you simply apply one evil
to en
now this PR G has degree D but we
require this PR g to have a stretch of
this n to the ceiling of d by 2 times
0.5 plus epsilon plus rho this might
sound a little complicated but roughly
what we are asking is that the stretch
should be more than n to the degree over
2 times 0.5 plus some any of any
constant and once you have a stretch
more than this then you can back-trace
epsilon and Rho and instantiate or so
this is a number to keep in mind n to
the D over to the ceiling times 0.5 and
when D is even then this translate that
it's just n to the degree over four okay
so our assumption states that this
distribution that I was telling is the
CI along with the PRG outputs look
indistinguishable in standard strength
sense from another distribution d2 which
consists of relatively samples again but
now instead of flesh output you have
Cooley random string of length M and
that's if that's not assumption okay and
you are asking standard
indistinguishability against all
polynomial time adversary's with
negligible advantage so I hope the
assumption is clear if anyone has any
questions please let me know
okay so let me now straight our main
result so we proved that if you are
willing to assume standard polynomial
hardness of the following assumptions as
the Blooey standard assumptions over
value in your maps sx th inviolate will
billion along with that if you assume
this assumption that I just described
GLW unique then you can construct a
public-key sub linearly efficient
functional encryption scheme directly
from these three okay so I now I want to
stress a few ponens and like just to
compare it with the LMS the thumbscrew
first we are only making use of
polynomial hardness to construct Fe we
are no longer requiring sub-exponential
time hardness which is non-standard and
then we directly construct public key
everything instead of secret classroom
so these are one of the two high-level
main differences and then once you have
this then you can bootstrap it to I know
using this transformation of the ten
scan Micronauts an N and on Sanjay okay
so just let's do some final comparison
with GL m assumption so I'm going to
write so this is a our assumption on the
left on the right we have the GLM
assumption so let me quickly recall what
j LM s assumption was like in just rough
detail there you had the same overall
structure they were elderly samples and
then there was a leakage which was the
polynomial evolution on on the errors
the errors were chosen from by the
domain like let's say - n - n
and in the second distribution you had
delivery samples but now instead of the
polynomial evolution you had formal
evaluations perturb with some small
value Delta J which was chosen adversely
by the adversity and they had to be with
some bounded integers and we were asking
we were asking that these two
distributions for any subject for some
sub-exponential size adversity is weakly
indistinguishable okay so now once we
have this thing we can just compare our
assumptions so first I would say
positive aspect of our assumption
that you are using PR geez so now we
have some cryptanalysis to back this up
second plus point is that now we work
with only polynomial size adversaries so
that's also good the third plus point
which I feel is that we are using
negligible advantage instead of 0.99
which really helps us in getting rid of
the security amplification step and our
construction become much more cleaner
and direct and also gives us better
quality assumptions and one of more and
and then one of them there's one more
plus point which is very nice is that
our assumption is no longer interactive
so remember in the jail ms exemption
these deltas were chosen by the
adversary so now there is this
completely non interactive assumption
and and that's about it for the plus
points but I also feel that there are
some negative points and let me state
that the main negative point is that we
are using error to be cool Ian as
opposed to standard n minus n to the N
and this might make the elderly part
slightly insecure so that is roughly
this some sort comparison that I wanted
to do so now let me describe the road
map of the construction so we actually
before I tell you the road map I need to
define a few notion mainly the notion of
partially hiding function infection
so what partially hiding function
encryption is it's just a generalization
of a normal regular functional infection
where you also for algorithms so let me
zoom in by month so there's a set up
algorithm which is serves the same
purpose then there is an encryption
algorithm but now as opposed to just
taking one input the encryption
algorithm will take two inputs x and y
and then it produces a ciphertext that's
like normal I feel but also it just
completely reveals the X part of the
input
so roughly intuitively we are not asking
the scheme to hide the X part of the
input and therefore we will call X the
public part and why the private part of
the message the keygen is the same takes
all circuit
massive peanut butter secretly for
circuit see and then you can decrypt
using this decryption algorithm to on C
of X comma Y so you learn joint in joint
functions of the input so it also has
some efficiency properties which are
traditionally considered in FFA
literature and I'm going to discuss only
one notion of sufficiency that is
generally useful in if you want to
construct I oh that's the notion of sub
linearity so what sub linearity says is
that the size of the cipher text is only
sub linear in the number of function
queries that that were still gets to me
okay so that's sub genera T and as we
all know that sub linear functional
encryption implies IO understand loss
from from very nice works therefore this
is a really important efficiency
definition finally let me also talk
about security for one minute so we are
not going to differ we're in the in this
talk I am NOT going to give you a proof
of security therefore let me just say it
on a high level roughly the security
requirement will just say something like
that the only thing that's revealed to
the adversary consists of the public
part of the ciphertext along with the
function outputs C evaluated an x and y
for any queries circuit or any queries
of circuit that the adversary minx so
that's security
and so this was pH Fe which which is
that as I was saying was the
generalization of Fe
so let me show you why it cap in the
definition captures standard entry and
the reason is that you can simply set X
to the public part to be bought and if
your circuit C is an arbitrary
polynomial is a polynomial size circuits
then then this captures a few dreamily
and then under some exponential loss you
can can construct io from that the one
of the more other notion that has been
emerging at the notion of functionality
that has been emerging is F comma to pH
Fe where F is denote some function class
class that you can evaluate on the
public part and to denotes the debris of
the the function in the private part of
the input so more precisely the function
looks like following will have the
following structure so C of XY is
summation IJ f IJ X so f IJ is in this
class F and then it gets multiplied with
F by I YJ so this is degree 2 in Y and
this compare this is summed up over all
indices I and J and this computation is
done modulo P where T is some modulus
that is fixed in the scheme okay and
this is really useful primitive in order
to construct IO and J LMS 19 showed how
to construct this where F was a constant
degree polynomials over ZP so they could
construct a pH everywhere for any plus F
which was a constant degree polynomial
over CP and they constructed a secret
variant secret key variant of that from
Bellino maps in this world we in fact
extend the result we construct a public
key variant instead of a secret key
barrier but this F now can be any
arbitrary polynomial a sized arithmetic
branching program and in fact it will
cover arithmetic NC 1 so it's even more
expressive in terms of functionality
note that I want to stress that this
public key variant is is essential that
it this is the thing that helps us in
order to construct public key Fe
directly ok so now once you have this
definition the road map let's dip all
the group F of G LMS and my already
appear to you that it is pretty singing
pretty complex and complicated so there
they started with this secret key NC 0
comma 2 fph Nephi where the public part
was constant depth circuits and then
they used it with fhe schemes and this
new assumption that they make Delta G to
construct a weakly secure sub linear
secret key Fe for constant depth boolean
circuits and then they did another
bootstrapping by using PR G's and then C
0 to construct sub linear secret key Fe
for circuits with weak security
and then after that they did security
amplification by relying on lwe and
under the under this they had to go
through a service some exponential size
loss in the assumption basically that
size of the adversity had to blow up by
some exponential factor in in the
reduction and then they once you have
something a secret key SV which is fully
secure then you can use this
transformation of B and PW to construct
xio and then you can use a scheme of g k
pv z which is a syntactic scheme
instantiated from lwe to get public key
Fe with this be NP double 16
transformation so that's how you
construct public Fe and then from there
you can do some exponential under sub
expression laws you can apply the
transformations for BB and AJ to get io
note that there is another
transformation that you could use to
directly get from Sabrina secret key Fe
which is that of K and T which first
construct an unbounded secret key Fe and
meaning that it can allow any number of
function key queries and then from there
under suffix financial advantage laws
you can apply another transformation of
ent to get to IO but I would like to
point that this transformation is at
least as more complicated than the PNP
doctrine so mission and if and therefore
it's not clear that it is any more
direct
so this is our road map and as you can
already see this is a lot of
simplification and we have lot of plots
which are which are not there in the
previous slide there the bootstrapping
steps and amplification steps are
completely out of the picture now so let
me describe what our transformation does
first it concerts this public key and C
1 comma 2 P HFE as I was saying that you
can have arithmetic branching programs
in the public component and degree do in
the private company so this we built
from standard bilinear wraps and then
you we construct another primitive
single safer text secret key function
encryption with linear key generation so
here the key generation step
linear in the secret key and then we use
our new assumption to build public here
fee now I want to remark something here
the first three things that I just wrote
down the ingredients they're actually
spiritually functionality-wise this the
purpose this term is quite similar to
what to these objects in fact this Delta
is a pseudo randomness assumption we
have a GW which is also silver and in
this function here we were using it
stretchy to achieve an expressive
functionality and we are using going to
use this to have more expressive
functionality and in fact if you look at
our construction here you will see some
it will be reminiscent of some
special-purpose extra Chi another point
I want to make is that this public key
NC 1 comma 2 FHP HFE is is used to
provide enforcement and this is what was
the purpose of secret key and C 0 to the
my PHP also but still our transformation
is much more direct and the mainly one
of the main reason behind this is that
we are going to provide a new liquid
resilience lemma new leakage resilience
lemma which is actually one of the
cornerstones of our paper and this is
something this is a new proof technique
that allows us to actually just use them
and directly construct we be carefree
with only polynomial loss in the size
and advantage in fact there are no
parallel repetitions anymore and and get
the completely obviates the need of any
security amplification or even any
bootstrapping and finally once you have
this public Fe you can just apply the
transformation of AJ and B we get ok
yeah I have a quick question so so if
you replace this new public key pH Fe
that you can strip it in this work in
the previous picture in the Jade in this
picture yeah does it simplify the J LMS
picture as well or it does not if I know
it does not you still need to do this
like you what you because this is a
weaker assumption right so it has a big
advantage like that so this kind of
propagates downwards
but what if we have Delta orgies with
the better bondage like technology as
ever that we did not know how to
construct mainly because because okay so
the way let me back it up okay so this
was our assumption so remember this is
polynomially bounded right these deltas
are also polynomial bounded so how can
you have something negligible here
because I mean it's going to reveal
something about Delta with some
advantage right yeah okay that makes
sense thank you so that was the main
reason and here the proof technique that
we do is like you're not going to we are
not going to there will be something
which is significantly different from J
LMS which allows us to do that basically
first of all our assumption only gives
negligible advantage and even after that
we need to take care of this issue that
meaning that Delta can be revealed out
of this so this is done via some new
leakage resilience technique this part
okay thank you thank you
so this is our comparison and as I
described our contribution so I would
skip to the next slide mainly we
construct all these three things and we
have given you proof technique and a new
proof okay so now let me jump to the
actually a significantly interesting
part we this is about crypt analysis and
constructing new PR G's which allows us
to instantiate our assumption so with
this I want to just recall the
assumption first so that we can keep and
handle on that our assumption had I just
want you to remember that our assumption
had two components of PR G and the
samples so any attack that you can think
of on these assumptions typically you
can break it in one of the following
categories you can think of them as
attacks on the PRG component alone you
can think of them as being attacks on by
the dlw component alone and then there
are attacks that make use of the joint
structure and the joint relation between
these two objects so these are the
attacks on the joint assumption
so let me now recap some of the main
known attacks that exist out there for
all these three categories so far binary
lw8 typically in literature the most
common attacks are the lactose reduction
attacks where you use lll or pkc kind of
algorithms to mount attacks then there
are these algebraic attacks mathematical
equation capturing the boolean key
constraints and so and so forth into
algebraic manipulation until an inverse
or an expectation is found
so that's algebraic attacks and then
there are attacks on PR G's and for PR g
is actually the literature is really
systematic and organized we have as a
community being able we have been
successful to actually identify three
main kinds of attacks and if your PR g
is guaranteed to be secure against those
attacks then it's generally considered a
really solid evidence that is secure so
those attacks are f to linear bias
attacks so where what you do is that you
take linear combinations of the PRG
outputs and try to construct something
that does not behave like a random
function meaning that in expectation it
does not have expectation of half it can
either like it doesn't have 50%
probability of both 0 and 1 so that's F
2 linear bias attacks then there is
another attacks that actually is coming
from sum of squares paradigm so just to
recall some squares is a really powerful
hierarchy that spilled on of convex
optimization that is built on semi
definite programs and in fact it
provides the front-runner of our
algorithms for constraint satisfaction
problems and it provides the best known
approximation algorithms for many of the
np-hard problems that exist out there so
it's a really powerful technique and
then there are algebraic attacks here
also wherein you use these mathematical
equations that you have and try to reuse
that to mount do algebraic manipulations
and mount algebraic attacks on that and
this can also be studied in conjunction
with what is known as case and
determined attacks where you get some
bits and then do your algebraic
derivation and then see if your guess
was correct in or
and so and so forth so this is about PRG
and then I was talking about attacks on
the joint assumption here unfortunately
we just know a single way of doing that
is by extending algebraic attacks mainly
you can exploit these equations which
arise from both they wish both the
components using by writing some
equations over F and if you left me and
can do problem bases computation on that
and it's really an interesting question
if you can come up with any other attack
that that does not use that is not is
not algebraic basically the question is
can you come up with more attacks in
this third category so that's that now
let me recap the tax on line LW with
binary noise so here as I told you in
the number of samples is linear then you
are good when you are when the number of
samples is square of the dimension then
it's broken in polynomial time due to
the work of a Ferengi however as I was
saying we work an intermediate regime
for us epsilon is some constant between
0 and 0.5 so for that there are two main
kinds of attacks one of them are lattice
attacks where we where we use these
lattice reductions to mountain-like
recover the secrets and so on so forth
so for that the heuristic running time
falls because the algorithm is this
quantity basically dimension divided by
log P to the power dimension by log P
and this can be made to be some
exponential if you set the modulus such
that Rho is less than 0.5 plus Epsilon
okay so this the reference for this is a
slide that I saw from demyans today then
for algebraic attacks for algebraic
attacks the picture is really nice it
turns out that in in sequence of words
named namely by Albrecht at all and then
follow-up chavatal they established that
the Grovner basis algorithms take this
much time to to the end to the two
Epsilon
very epsilon was this okay so that's
about algebraic attacks now let me
discuss some attacks on the PRG but even
before that I need to tell you what
candidates we have for PRG so we are
going to use gold egg GOG and I'm sure
all of you might know what it is but
like me nevertheless quickly describe
what it is so bull-dyke PRG is indexed
with two things a hypergraphs
age and predicate P P is typically a
constant local predicate it's a boolean
predicate it takes as bits of input and
outputs in 0 1 and now this hyper graph
will basically tell you how to evaluate
the PRG in this type of graph there will
be two sets of vertices one set is this
the other set is that in the first set
there are nodes corresponding to the
input ok so there are n inputs so there
will be n nodes and the second set
consists of nodes corresponding to the
outputs so there are M outputs there are
M nodes now it's a bipartite graph so
every node in the output set is going to
be connected with L input nodes ok so
the degree of also note is L and then
this rule this tells you how to evaluate
the PRG basically in order to evaluate
output bid you take the corresponding
node and apply the predicate on the
neighbors of that node in the neighbors
here in the input node so that's what
you do and this way you can evaluate the
PRG and typically this type of graph is
chosen to have high expansion properties
but you can make sure that this happens
by sampling at randomly so this tells
you how to evaluate the PRG now
typically we are working with multi near
degree and this the PRG is a local so
you can obviously see that the degree is
going to be less than L that's because
any degree as a boolean function can be
a degree alpha so the degree has is less
than equal to L and typically what these
PRG provides they provide the stretch
that looks like n to the Omega L that
means end to the some constant time cell
and that's what you want to optimize
here
this depends significantly on what
predicates that you are choosing so
let's look at the one of the predicates
that when in fact one of the first
studied predicates that is the predicate
of TSA it stands for try Simon and so it
takes five bits of inputs and and then
exerts the first three of them and then
exhausts it with product of last two so
that's it that's TSA and you can see
that it says locality five over f2 it
has a degree of 2 because this is the
only nonlinear part when you write it
down as a polynomial over the reals it
turns out it has a degree 5 so you don't
get any benefit here and this is
believed to be secure for against all
some exponential time algorithms as long
as the number of output bits is less
than n to the 1.5 minus epsilon where
epsilon is some cons any I would be
constant you can choose it to be as well
as you want and really the evidence for
this is very well founded basically
there aren't known F to linear attacks
lower bounds from which will provide a
little bit more and then there are SOS
lower bounds against a long time this
was also proven you know down a bit more
and and then for algebraic attacks
actually we do not have any lower bounds
but all known algebraic attacks takes of
exponential time so that seems good and
the question is can be used to
instantiate our assumption and turns out
the answer is no and the reason for that
is that the degree is 5 and remember we
want the stretch to be more than ceiling
of 5 by 2 times 0.5 so this yeah so this
this thing is 3 so n to the 3 times 0.5
which is n to the 1.5 and turns out with
this stretch actually the predicate is
broken so you need the stretch to be
more than n to the 1.5 plus constant and
you can't handle that
so we need to do something and let's for
the next part of the talk let's focus on
how you can build a predicates which
give us what we want and how you can
also make sure that they are not ok so
turns out what PRG is there are really
nice systematic study and turns out that
we have boiled down to just two
parameters that suffice for
parameterizing upper bounds lower bounds
and the running times for all all of the
three attacks known so these were
introduced I mean they existed much
before but actually this kind of formal
theorem statement appeared in the work
of Asheville government love it so let
me tell you what these parameters are so
the first parameter is independence so
what is schema is independence
we say that a predicate P is K wise
independent if for any if you excite
that with any set of variables
corresponding to a set of size less than
equal to K minus 1 and you then you
exhort with the predicate then this does
not make the predicate unbalanced namely
we say that it's K by is independent if
X or of the variables is ex-ored with
predicate takes probability with
probability 1/2 over the inputs maps to
0 with probability 1/2 it webb's to 1 so
it's an expectation this is 1/2 so
that's what KY is independence being the
definition clear ok another parameter of
importance is rational degree and
rational degree is a degree over f2 ok
so what is rational degree it's it's
just minimum degree for which you can
find out two degree polynomials qnr such
that when you multiply P with Q you get
R over f2 X construction so that's
rational degree okay let me repeat
myself
rational degree is a degree e minimum
degree is such that for which you can
find two functions qnr of degree e such
that P times Q is part
okay so once the
parameters are clear then actually this
story is really I mean actually I'm
cheating a little bit from the sense
that you can work with more fine-grained
aspects of rush to find brain variants
or actively to get more fine-grained
trade-offs but asymptotically they don't
change the story of whole lot so
therefore for for simplicity I will just
work with these two parameters so for
linear attacks it turns out there are
polynomial time attacks when the stretch
into the S is greater than n to the K by
2 so I am going to denote the stretch
with 10 to the S but for these this
slide and then there are theoretical no
bounds when this stretch is less than n
to the minimum of K comma E divided by
18 so this is when you can prove lower
bounds this is another extreme so we are
in the middle we do not have theoretical
lower bounds and we there no polynomial
time attacks so it turns out the best
known attacks are some exponential when
when the stretch is less than minimum of
K by 2 comma E minus F minus epsilon
where epsilon is any arbitrary small
constant ok for SOS attacks turns our
picture is really crisp and there is a
tight characterization so when the
stretch is more than K by 2 then they'll
follow mistime attacks when the stretch
s is less than n to the K over 2 minus
epsilon times this constant K by 2 minus
1 then provably that accidents in 2 to
the n to the epsilon time and so there's
a very sharp phase shift from K by 2 to
K by 2 minus small so that's as far as
algorithms for algebraic attacks there
are polynomial time attacks when into
the stretch is more than L to the e ok
and there are provable lower bounds when
s is less than e minus 1 over 8 so this
was also proven in the world of K of 16
and for this the best known attacks are
sub-exponential when s is even less than
e minus epsilon and this is you can find
these theorem statements in a very nice
work of co2 at all on concrete security
of PR jeez
so the main takeaway that I want to give
is that it's easy to build predicates
that resist all modes of exponential
attacks when you set m to be less than
minimum of K by 2 comma e minus Epsilon
so our goal is just to find our
predicates which have higher actively
and high kimba's independence how high
rational degree it has to be greater
than dy for how high K buys independence
it has to be greater than D by 2 where D
is the degree of your double real degree
of unity
ok so that's the goal
so let's now let's now jump straight
into it let's just look at all the very
case that exists out there and see if
you can instantiate so the first
candidate that we can use is that of X
or majority
it's one of considered one of the most
secure predicates out there so it's to a
local predicate it takes 12 inputs ok
and then what it does it exhausts the
first L of them and then exhaust it with
the majority function applied on the
remaining L okay and for this it turns
out this is L plus 1 y is independent
why because these are L wise independent
comes from the fact that you are
exerting L independent variables here
and then since majority is balanced it's
a balanced function therefore it
provides one more degree of freedom so
it's L plus 1 that boolean to the real
degree when you write it down as a
polynomial turns out it's 2 to the 8 to
L and it's it's actually I leave it as
an exercise for you to verify the third
thing is that the rational degree is
actually L plus 1 over 2 now this is not
something that if that is easy to see
but it's actually proven in the world of
CM 0 1 in 2001 where they prove that
this is the maximum possible rational
degree for any predicate so it was L
plus 1 by 2 the maximum stretch
therefore you can get from this from our
intuition is n to the L plus 1 by 2
minus Delta
for this what we require is n to the
ceiling of D by two times point five
plus epsilon it works out to be n into
the L just L by 2 plus Epsilon
now you can set epsilon and Delta so
that this quantity is greater than that
and then you can use a constant rate but
this should already seem like very tight
margin because the maximum stretch is n
to the L plus 1 by 2 and required is n
to the other two so this is not a room
to play in order to address this issue
we actually consider a very nice
predicate that was proposed in the work
of Lombardi in Waco noting where they
proposed this modification of 30 as a
predicate which we did not try some
parity and and tspa it is a fine local
predicate so it exhausts the first three
of them as like what is a predicate then
it exhausts it with something else
so in DSA you exhorted with X 4 times X
5 now they are going to XR it with X 4
translated with X to product with X 5
translated X 3 so it's just TSA where
these last two variables are translated
with some varial variables here so they
are no longer dependent so for this it
turns out that it's three wise
independent it's this is somewhat
non-trivial to see but you can believe
me on it and I'll also show you how
later how the degree over the reals
actually drops down to just three it's
no longer to dignify predicate and this
is a race this was really a surprising
observation at that point and I will
also give you a formal proof in more
generality than than this and finally
there actually is two and it's in fact
the same STS a but actually it is
preserved by this
so therefore the maximum stretch you can
hope for is n to the 3 by 2 minus Delta
in fact the authors themselves approved
lower bounds for n to the one point two
five minutes Epsilon
whereas the required stretch is just n
to the 1 plus epsilon so now you get a
lot of room to play with those
parameters so what we do next is that we
read you we give our own degree having
our transformation which it literally
reduces their degree by a factor of two
and it's inspired heavily from the body
so suppose you had an original predicate
which does xrg so as an example here
it's gee it was majority situating it's
a predicate so this looked like this
okay you XOR first all of them and then
excite it with G applied on the
remaining else our transformation what
it does is that it takes XOR of first
step and then exerts it with G applied
on translated set of variables so namely
instead of X L plus I input here you're
going to replace it with X L plus I XOR
X I so it's translated with variables
from here so that's the transformation
for this let me now compare what this
transformation gives like let me now
give you why this is useful so let's
start with X our majority we had already
worked out parameters for its own
majority there actually was L plus 1 by
2 the key wise independence was L plus 1
and the degree was 2l now let's see what
happens in the in this predicate so the
rational degree actually just preserves
it's the same key wise independence drop
a little bit
it goes from L plus 1 to L and there's a
reason behind that and I will show that
later the degree from 2l just drops down
to L and so what it does is that if your
maximum stretch was n to the L plus 1 by
2 minus Delta using our intuition that
does not change a lot it just goes to n
2 L by 2 minus Delta but the required
stretch drops from n to the L by 2 to n
to the L plus 1 by 4 then that gives a
lot of room so I have a probably very
dumb question um which is just so you
wrote equality's here everywhere are
they literally equality is like no
matter what the predicate is no oh I see
okay yeah in general actually I write
down what happens in general actually
turns out that no matter what G you
choose the degree
is going to be precisely Ellen is
exactly going to be I'll write down in
just a minute
I see probably the worst case is like
geez X or something you're like okay
yeah sure cool yeah it does not matter
actually what G is for for K and D only
thing that changes is the rash Livie
- degree is preserved in our
transcription okay so let me now follow
up on Noah's question and understand
what is exactly going on with this
transformation for that we need to
actually understand a little bit of
Fourier representation and the reason
for that is that sometimes the things
that are not evident to naked eye
becomes really crystal clear when you
look at those same things in Fourier
representation so just to recall there
are two ways of writing will it function
the first way is to write like this your
boolean function takes is input from 0 1
to the l20 101 but there's another way
you can treat you can give different
meanings to inputs so in traditional
sense 0 1 is your input true and false
in Fourier sense you can assign them to
be 1 and minus 1 ok so one will stand
for 0 and 1 and minus 1 will stand for 1
and the reason is 0 and 1 from additive
group in F to 1 n minus 1 is for
multiple
integers okay so so then you can denote
your function like that in the standard
setting your input variables are from 0
1 and they are denoted by small X I and
you can write this polynomial as a
polynomial of the real this is known as
the multi linear expansion I told you
about this how to do that in four-year
domain this X I is going to capital X I
will denote as the input this is now in
plus 1 minus 1 it is literally related
like 1 minus 2 times small X I so just a
linear transform and you can also write
it as the Fourier expansion as it's
going to be some expansion you can just
write down the multi linear expansion
for this polynomial now there are some
very basic properties that are satisfied
first is that the this output P hat is
related with the small P with P of x1
through xn for unemployed and small
inputs namely it's just 1 minus 2 times
that and a second one of the more
important properties is that if you have
X or in the real and the standard
setting sorry X and X 2 then it just
becomes multiplication in the Fourier
void and this is what I will call as the
Fourier expansion of people for your
expansion so that's all I need
in order to be able to understand what's
going on in setting so let's first look
at rational degree and see if you have a
initial predicate like this and the
final predicate like that where the
variables are used sorry okay these
variables are reused like it has some
translation I claim that the rational
degree of this predicate is the same as
rational degree of p2 and roughly why
this is happening is because there is a
really nice linear transformation
between variables namely you may map X 1
to X 1 XL to XL and then XL plus 1 goes
to XL plus 1 X or X 1 X L plus 2 goes to
XL plus 2 X or X 2 X 2 L goes to X 12 X
or X so namely the the bottom half is
literally transformative
transformed as X L plus y goes to x LX
plus sorry itself aside X or X where the
top half is unchanged so this is an
invertible linear transform but if you
have any decomposition like that P 1 Q
equal to R there these qnr of degree
then you can apply this transformation
of variables and you'll get a
decomposition of the other namely P 2
times Q prime equal to 1/5 where degree
of Q Prime and alpha are just the same
as degree and q FR q and hours literally
Q Prime in R prime R just transformation
applied on this Q n 1 so rationally we
speak of because of that so so far we
have not used of used any for your
representation here but this will become
evident when I talk about how what
happen
degree over there yes so here what I
want to claim is that this is your track
sorry sorry about that
you have this is your transformed
barricade I claim that the degree of
this is precisely L no matter what G you
choose okay and the reason for that is
that you can write it is in Fourier
transform you get P of G the XOR becomes
product so capital X I product i from 1
to L times the Fourier transform applied
on the other function G now you can
write the full expansion of this
function which is going to be some
polynomial like this remember the inputs
that G takes is an XOR of two things so
I'm going to replace it with
multiplications in the folio world so X
L plus 1 X or X 1 becomes X 1 times X L
plus 1 X 2 L X or X L becomes X L times
X 2 L and then I'll write it as a sum
these are the coefficients and this is
the monomial corresponding to the status
so for every set there will be X I and
there will be xn plus L now remember
each X I square is either plus 1 or
minus 1 and so X is either plus 1 or
minus 1 so X I square is 1 so therefore
you can simplify this and take this
thing inside and what you get is just a
homogeneous debris L polynomial over the
reals and that's why this has this
people going to have a degree of L and
it's also be it will also be L wise
independent roughly this might not be
clear but this is another way of stating
K by is independent which says that
predicate is K by is independent P P is
K Y is independent if you can write P as
in the Fourier transform like 1 2 minus
sorry X I and then PS where the size of
the set is
greater than equal to K so all only
coefficient that survived
I have degree more than equal to K so k
buys independent means if and one give
so that's why itself is independent and
that's it that's our transformation and
finally so yeah that completes that path
this part of my discussion over this PRG
now let me talk about the third kind
category of attack and I will you
briefly describe about it so we work
with the we're talking about algebraic
attacks on the joint assumptions and we
follow in the same approach like with
the way albrecht at all and Chow at all
so what we did was that we can write
these equations first equations are the
ones that come from Giuliana T of the
error second construction the second
equations are from the PRG
relations namely you have been given
some PID outputs and then we initialize
systems to analyze this and the question
is can you solve this to recover s and
based on our initial calculations it
seems that the global basis algorithm
should also take some exponential time
and we're kind of using same inherent
assumptions that were made in the
initial words to capitalize binary as
Dewey and this is something that Amit
also talked about in his talk in the
Simon's workshop on obfuscation on where
there was a session on obfuscation okay
so that is about algebraic attacks and
roughly this table kind of summarizes
the state of non attacks so these are
the algorithms that we consider the SOS
is only over the PRG because these are
lattice reductions applying only to
binomials we governor bases are applied
on both PR G's and lwe and then CDMA
represents the state of art is there
algebraic attacks on the PRG part and we
instantiated these predicates DSA XOR
and low-degree major version of majority
we calculated what is what is required
which looks like this
what are we actually getting using this
we actually calculated back calculated
values of epsilon and rose we said row
to be epsilon by degree and once we did
that we found out running times and they
behaved some exponential in all these
parameters in n sub expression in N and
they are raised to the powers which are
constant which are roughly like this
this anyone have any questions about any
of the attacks or PRG constructions or
this okay so let me go see
so next unfortunately I don't have too
much time about this but let me now give
you talk to you a little bit about the
new proof technique that construct in
order to get security proof and we call
this so okay so let me actually actually
actually generalize to applies to a lot
of general things but I'm going to give
you one specific use case where where we
can apply this lemma so here is the use
case so in typical FPS games if you
consider for example in AJ LMS and in
gel ms and other works typically what
you learn is some group exponentiated to
some small error where this error comes
is related to the some fhe cipher text
of the message that you want to hide and
this is typically smudged by some pseudo
randomness generator okay and adversity
gets the gets to ask let's say some n to
the 1 plus epsilon queries okay now it
turns out there for us to be able to
recover the output this error plus the
PRG has to be bounded by a polynomial
otherwise we won't be able to do the
straight log and so this routes a lot of
pressure on our assumption because this
is only polynomially bigger than the
error and you can you can information
theoretically hide this so this much
llamas that exist out there they don't
apply in order to handle this issue
these works typically find a workaround
by using security amplification and this
significantly blows up the quality of
the assumption and also makes it very
complex so what are llama proves is that
if you are if you want to hide a message
m and you are given a fetch encryptions
of m along with that you learn some
bounded number let's say n to be 1 plus
epsilon where n is the size of the
ciphertext you learn these efis for
function if I merged with an error which
is only polynomially times bigger so how
big it's just the number of Kony's times
the bound of each error times some
security parameter if you smudge it with
only that quantity which is still
polynomial that doesn't and if you only
smudge it with some polynomial bound
noise what we show is that this doesn't
hurt security at all and you can still
argue that encryption of m0 is
encryption is indistinguishable from
encryption of m1 and in order to do so
and in fact negligibly we do not make we
do not in fact we are able to show this
that these distributions are negligible
close and in order to do so we actually
develop some new techniques based on
ideas coming from hardness amplification
literature and so that's also really
interesting because typically in algebra
word we make information theoretic
arguments first and then a computational
here we are only making a computational
argument in order to prove this in order
and I think I won't have time to cover
the entire proof so I think I will call
it for the day but if you have any
questions or if you still want me to
cover it do let me know depending on the
time it will take me around to 10-15
minutes to do that I think you shouldn't
take 10 minutes if you want so we have
10 minutes okay
good so let me do the kind of okay let's
do a sketch of proof and then we'll see
so so we are learning EF of Fi
which is an effigy at all right so this
is an effigy error and we are learning
and then we are we learn it with not
directly we learn it something that gets
added to it and that's what's added is a
smudging noise which is let's say Paul
polynomial vigor so ii ii i tilde is
between 0 to Q times V times lambda and
error e fi sits in between minus b and b
okay and we learn it for how many values
for q values now i want you to look at
this distribution so there are two ways
of sampling from the same distribution
okay so i'll move on to the next page
she let me make only okay can you need
everyone see this okay so so I want you
to look at this distribution efi plus
ETA line now this distribution once you
fix the CFI is going to be uniform
between efi + 0 + EF i + QB
okay that's because once you fix efi
then this is the thing
now you can plot it on the number line
0q b lambda and this is slightly
disturbed efi and then here Phi here efi
+ QB lambda
okay now the really the thing is that
you can equivalently sample this from
the following distribution okay so you
find out you find a canonical
distribution so let that distribution is
the following so this is qblambda
we're going to be uniform between be and
here it'll be QB lambda minus B now this
this just this interval is definitely
sitting inside this so an equivalent way
of something from this is that with
probability Q be lambda minus to be
divided by QB lambda sample from I will
call it D and we'll call it call this
probability SP and with probability 1
minus P you sample from this set EF i a
comma EF i cubed and minus p comma
whatever okay this is equivalent now
just think about it so that means line
this so i'm going to add one page oh oh
no it's here okay so what this means is
that if you look at this probability
it's pretty large its QB it's actually 1
minus 2 by Q lambda 2 by Q lambda right
and now you're making Q queries so an
expectation what's the problem how many
of the errors is going to lie outside
this interval of D that I that I told
you so an expectation number of samples
outside this interval D of B and Q be
lambda minus B
this is an expectation this is this is
something like two over lambda okay so
this is the expectation which is pretty
small and in fact with probability
lambda to the with probability less with
probability something like 1 minus 1 by
lambda to the C at most C of them C
values will lie outside D okay so this
gives this this should already leave the
bell that actually the information that
you learn is not actually that much
typically in a typical circumstance you
are going to learn C indices on which
you you're outside and and then for that
those many indices you are going to
learn approximately logarithm of B plus
Q B lambda bits okay so this is
information theoretically that we learn
now I want you to look at a lemma that
in general helps us to convert
information theoretic arguments like
this into a poof and that lemma is this
liquid simulation lemma that is was
proposed by JP 14 and Reese and it was
also studied later on so what is a lemma
C is that is take any ID with
redistribution from 0 1 to the N and
let's say you have any function such
that the length of that the output
length of the function is bounded by L
so f is some auxilary information over X
then it says that take any X and any F
applied on X this for every size of
adversity that you want and any
advantage epsilon you can find a
function that efficiently mimics F you
can find a circuit that mimics F but
it's much more efficient meaning that
the size of F is only s epsilon to the
minus 2 times 2 to the L so
s is the size of the adversity that you
want to handle epsilon is the advantage
that you want to fool with and 2 to the
L is just the L is the length of the
output that you want to simulate so what
this is that you can find a circuit such
that this is Essex and are
indistinguishable from X comma H of X
but now H is small ok so what so what it
says it just gives you a way of
converting something inefficient or
information theoretically large to
something which is efficient and that's
exactly what we do here bias some
arguments and actually that I think that
will require me some more a lot I like
quite a bit of time to formally kneel
down the arguments but I hope I am able
to convey you the main idea and I think
the paper will be out really soon it's
not out there and we will try to push it
you know few days so you could take a
look from there about the follicles so
very much any questions first of all
thank you very much I use for the
wonderful talk and people can unmute
themselves and and now if yeah feel free
to ask any questions now I think it mean
just unmute themselves and ask questions
you don't need to type in the chat so
just a quick clarification on my part if
I understand the leakage this nikich
lemma that you were mentioning basically
the lemma is saying that you can
approximate a very inefficient function
with an efficient function as long as
you know the size of the circuit loss
that you want to be indistinguishable
with respect to yeah so if you know the
adversity size you can officially make
the inefficient function with something
smaller and something smaller you can
choose by like you need to know what I
want is you want to fool way then what's
the length of the information that you
want to mimic and in your work you are
only working with polynomial time or
nominated bursaries so I'm assuming with
the size of the circuit that or the size
s that you're picking here is something
some exponential exactly s is polynomial
yeah and epsilon is also polynomial so
if you want to construct Fe but you will
when you said that
so does this s appear only in the proof
but when you do this sort of the setup
of the entire system then okay that's
why it's basically it is more like a
non-uniform deduction exactly so we have
an adversary and let's say it claims
that I will fool I will break your
scheme as 1 by lambda to the C then I'm
going to give you a reduction which
shows that he cannot break it with 1 by
lambda the C okay so that's how you
argue negative and just just one more
clarification so the assumptions that
you have are you how to put this I'm
just wondering okay if this
non-uniformity appears in the proof does
this non-uniformity also sort of appears
in some sense in one of the assumptions
it doesn't seem to be the case right no
wait you're asking if the assumptions so
the the g LW e be assumption that he
provided I'm just wondering that
assumption as she stated has just stated
that okay hey for all polynomial-time
universities the advantage is negligible
that's it right yeah exactly
standard indistinguishable do that in
other words thanks so if we do other
people have any more questions and you
can you can also feel free to reach out
to me or any of the others if you have
any questions after so thanks very much
I use and thanks all of you for joining
this today as well as for all the
previous Latta seminars so so I think
today is the last seminar that we were
running as part of the series and I hope
all of you were able to get something
out of it and all the videos are already
posted on almost all the videos are
already posted
on Simon's YouTube page for all the
seminars and no one do you want to add
anything to that no just thanks everyone
and I hope everyone you know takes care
and as well yeah that's more important
sorry Thank You Noah that's a lot more
important yeah why bad yeah
thanks everybody okay take care bye
thanks I owe Saul you have to stop the
recording my bad